the
from
Oh my gosh.
Hello.
I think I think we.
What's up?
Can everyone hear my girls?
I can hear you.
Hi.
Got it.
Great.
Alright.
Right.
Go ahead.
Let's do our introductions around this round table.
Okay, let's do this introduction around this round table.
I'm ready.
Okay, okay.
You may plus first.
Okay.
You may plus.
You may plus go.
I said no.
The other first.
Hi.
My name is Melissa Sarky and I like strawberries.
Nice to meet you all.
Yay.
Shut up.
Don't talk to me.
Oh.
You like that sometimes.
I guess I'm next.
Yeah.
Hello.
I'm Rhea Nevermore and I am the goat girl.
You may plus first generation remedy.
Yay.
Yes.
Wow.
Okay.
Wait.
I can't hear them.
I can't turn them off.
Can you hear them now?
Oh shoot.
Sorry.
I had you guys off on my desktop.
Hold on.
I'm so dumb.
Okay.
You may plus first and second generation.
Coyote maybe.
I can hear them.
They're going to get up.
Turn off the damn echo.
Oh.
Oh my God.
That's so bad.
Scuff.
Oh my God.
The voices.
Oh my god, the voices!
Oh my god!
It's screaming and echoing, it's killing me.
Can you please fix it? Like, that's crazy.
Oh wait, that was my laugh.
Can you still hear it? Or is it gone?
I can hear it, yeah. No, it sounds fine, sorry.
It's good, you're fine.
Girl, how loud do you have your headset?
Me?
Yeah.
I fixed it, I fixed it, I fixed it, I fixed it.
Oh, I'm stupid! Oh my god, I had it turned down! Oh my god!
Welcome to the Via Lour and Yuma Plus collab where we are scuffed even through the beginning,
even though we met an hour before and set this all up.
It was more than an hour.
It's giving poopy.
Speaking of poopy, let me go.
Alright poopy, take it away.
Take it away, take it away.
Hi Yumi, I'm Yumi from Yuma Plus Special Generation Remedy.
I'm a virtual playing doctor, nice to meet you.
Yeah, nice to meet you.
Why do I feel like I'm an alcohol anonymous?
I'm rain and I'm the problem.
Fantastic.
Okay.
Seriously, who are you?
Now for Via Lour!
Hey, I'm scrawny, I'm Scottish, you can't even mix my voice up with anyone in this lobby
and I will not tolerate otherwise, thank you.
Okay, I'll go, I'll go.
Hello, my name is Mercy Modies from Via Lour Gen 1 in Dolce.
Nice to meet you.
Woo, woo, woo, woo.
Woo, woo, woo.
Me?
I guess you're wrong.
I'm a Viridulee from Gen 1 in Bold.
I'll be a lore.
Yay.
Nice to meet you, Mommy.
Wassup, I'm Shibi Cotton bum but you can call me anytime.
I love it!
Yay!
Thank you so much.
That was lit.
Okay.
Now that introductions are done.
Wait.
Is the introductions done?
They're the line.
Yeah.
Can we kill each other now?
Get out.
Okay.
Bye.
Going through this cross.
Okay.
How do I know where?
That would be good.
You have to do the follow the arrows or something.
You have arrows?
But you don't have arrows.
It's like the yellow one.
I don't have arrows.
I'm on X games mode.
Oh.
Never mind.
I'm on beginner mode.
Oh.
I'm in my total baby mode.
You guys okay?
Nerf yourself.
You guys are good.
Man.
That's what I need to go.
You guys go up.
You want to go to the car with me?
Okay.
Three, two, one.
Go!
Man.
Oh, awesome.
Who's dead?
Already?
Can you hear them now?
What?
It was in me.
It was Amy.
Oh, my God.
Amy's at the garbage chute.
I literally just saw her.
I came from the fricking.
I just came from communication.
And Amy is fucking standing over the body of rain.
Holy crap.
No.
Don't even fucking lie.
I'm sorry, but you're into...
No.
Is that the best...
Right.
Sorry.
That's the best you've got.
I walked in on it.
It's literally a...
A-Y-M-E.
It's the Sonic Heroes...
It's the fucking Shadow Roleplayer.
Yeah, okay.
The only guilty thing I have to admit is that I like Shadow,
but I didn't...
I didn't do this.
I promise.
Did Stroni set you up?
Yeah, absolutely.
You gotta believe it.
Hey, you up.
Are you fucking having a laugh?
Amy, are you joking?
I was literally at the gas canister, watching you as you go to pull the lever,
and then fucking Snape, rain in half.
Her fucking torso is like left behind.
I'm sorry, but that was a cute...
Open up my stream.
I don't know what there's anything to do with them.
I don't know who to vote for.
Open up.
Open up my stream right now.
I'm not being gaslit by selling a Sonic...
A fricking Shadow the Hedgehog streamer right now.
I'm not being gaslit.
I'm not being gaslit by a fricking Sonic the Hedgehog's son.
I will say that I did see...
I did see Amy stand over the body.
The body immediately just be like,
fuck you now, that's not fair.
Amy, I'm sorry, but you seem suspicious.
I'm sorry.
Believe me, my baby girl, I would never...
I would never have had a friend.
I'm sorry, Amy.
If it's not Amy, I'm voting for Stroni next round.
Why am I getting in trouble?
Obviously it's going to say imposter.
You're welcome, Sheebie.
You're actually welcome for doing half of the work.
Now you all go find the other imposter while you're at it.
I'll do it.
I'll try my best.
Goddamn, Stroni, I fucking love you.
What do you mean, though?
You heard the tune, but you don't hear them.
See you in death, baby girl.
What?
Oh my god, I can't believe they all...
Are you guys stupid or dumb?
Yeah, she's trying to get rid of Remini.
Wait, you didn't do it.
What?
You didn't do it.
Stroni.
She didn't do it.
You didn't do it?
Mother.
Wait, wait, Mercy...
Mercy says you saw it.
You didn't do it.
No, it's not.
Mercy reported.
I walked in.
I don't know about this.
You just walked in.
No, what?
You didn't eliminate Remini.
What?
I protected you.
I'm gonna broke you my shit.
If somebody kills me, it was Stroni.
Wait, but...
It was Stroni.
What?
I'm so fucking good.
Mercy!
Mercy, no!
I don't understand.
I did it.
Wait, how did the game end?
The people were still alive.
Oh, they probably double killed.
I hate you guys.
You knew when Stroni talks like that,
I know it's fucking her.
That's her tone.
Oh, Jesus.
He didn't nasty whore.
Fensive, so fast.
That is Stroni's tone.
Come on.
What?
Wait, wait, wait.
It didn't matter.
Hold it.
If you guys hear me.
Yeah?
I feel so betrayed.
Wow, hang on.
I can't believe that this happened.
I am so hurt.
My ass home.
We're so hurt by this development.
I didn't see anything.
Is there anything?
Anything?
Defense.
Amy, what kind of defenses I didn't do it.
You had no alibi.
Yeah?
The candlestick was in the lounge.
The bill yard room had the freaking pool cue in it.
Like what was that alibi?
We got a pretty grand play.
I did do it.
Clue reference.
I think the world is heated.
I love shadow the hedgehog.
Eventually I was like, I'm gonna be accused by a shadow the hedgehog lover
Johnny doesn't go down without a fight
Hey boost begin with
Oh, it's so funny
Oh, thank God. Hopefully this time I should be the imposter
I'm coming for you Johnny
If you're fucking coming for me, I'm coming up you
I'll be a good little girl. I'll do my test
And it cannot be that bad
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do do-do-do-do-do-do-do
Sorry. I just coughed in your ear. Oh my gosh. I thought you had covid. You're gonna get...
It's okay, it's okay, it's okay. It's okay. It's a flu here.
Oh, this is disgusting. Ah, you're worse than the imposter
I
Shadowed the hedgehog. No, no, let me talk
Okay, I found the body let the rabbit speak. Um, so I was doing electrical. It's coming from electrical and I walked up
And uh, actually, I don't know where the hell the map works. Hold on. Let me let me look at the map
You can walk up near and in between reactor and security
Mm-hmm. Oh
That was I mean I am I'm going to vouch for rare and pink because she was near me all the way in
Navigation, I saw her go in the opposite direction. So I think yeah, yeah
Yeah, she caught me like she had caught it. Oh, it's Johnny Ray
Rouching for one another she be claiming. She saw it. So Azura mimosa and rain y'all looking so what do you what do you guys have to
Say for yourselves. I
Was in
It was it was not me
Yeah
Because a strongy I was with strongy, then I went to security and I saw
I didn't see who killed I mean between security
Yeah, but I was in between security and reactor. I did see rain
I did see rain and admin so Azura and mimosa are now the most likely suspects unless she be you're playing mind game
So Azura mimosa and she be are all sus now. I'm less ventilation was taken in electrical
Which unfortunately I don't believe a word you say Azura
At the table I'm sitting at the table because I'm having audio issue
Did you
Don't know who to vote for then I'm gonna vote for mimosa just because I love my mimosa
But you're the most likely target at the moment
Okay, who was the person that said they walk to security. I'm gonna skip cuz I don't know was me. I'm gonna skip
I don't know who to vote for
Azura and mimosa have abstained for voting. How fucking curious
Azura is the most fucking likely. I'm keeping an eye on Azura
He walks by
I
Unless it's mercy, I bet what what why me
Why I think she's good
It's not me
I think it's rain
Very fucking curious
What is this wait a moment TV who was attacking you
Ice mercy walk by me and disappeared into the nether I do believe it might be her no
What was the area on the left give me the map? I
Was right next to you in admin. No, I was alone with rain and Rhea and scrawny
I was with in rain. I think it was rain. Yeah, it was rain
No, it's not I can't believe you would do such a thing to me
Why mercy
I
Was actually aiming for rain, but I don't know how to the kill
Mercy walk right past me and I'm surprised you didn't kill me then cuz I was just like talking to myself
She shut up, I wanted to let you all live
Being so kind as an imposter letting you live
I'm red not blue goddamn
They're all liars here
Arbitrars
I
Take a break, okay, I'll come back
Where did I need to go now?
Reactor now it's time to survive
Don't worry. I'll start screaming bloody murder. Is this the reactor?
Yes
Is in frickin electrical and who does stumble upon puri Rio's dead body again?
I
Literally open the door because the door just got closed in my face me and
Opens and then I mean I mean comes out and then
Back at the vent section and Rio's sitting dead with her weak orbs, so I
Mean
I can't stop you
Listen to me
She literally goes I was an electrical I tell you I find the dead body of Rio an electrical and you go
She goes I'm an electric
I
Don't know
It also might be mimosa because no one was
No, I have not seen Azura, where's the where's her body probably by the table again
Excuse me
I
Mercy void for me, so when you see me
No, when it goes all when strong ease and I know we impose start vote mercy
Mercy mercy always
He's a posture
If you want to lose this crew mate have fun, but I'm here at win and you guys are being daft right now
It's clearly Marys say for one
We know it's not she be
Right when I float away in space and it says strong he was a weak crew mate everyone turned to mercy and vote for her
Thank you very much
Oh my god
Mercy will accuse someone and vote for somebody who is who is the imposter and accusing her which is so slow to get back
And then strongy gets so defensive
Why does she have a midget as a pet
Oh, I can't I can't eat so we you see a wee thing it's a wee thing. Oh, it's a wee thing
Who's missing who's missing it's a wee
Oh mercy's got an ipad yeah, I got an ipad and she has a little heart
I'm not sitting. Yeah. Well, I'm just having a week. I go
Anyway, so what I was always right. Anyway, everyone thinks I'm just so mad right now
I'm so
I'm gonna sit in the corner and be upset. Exactly. I can't wait to murder. I crave more blood
My god, why am I imposter again?
I can still hear you I like to
You like to
I have a buddy. Hey, what's going on?
Yeah, just go here. No, go. No, what? Oh, you go here. I use it. Oh, you can't use it. Okay
Because I'm imposter I can't use it. Oh my gosh, stop lying that no way you are
Oh
I'm still having audio issues, so I'm just chilling this one. Hi, everyone. It's going on. No, no, no, me most will stay away from me
You guys
Rodney, I don't like that. I don't like that. I don't like this. This is sorry. That's suspicious. I'm getting chased by mercy halfway across the canteen
Can I do this one?
Is it? Hmm?
Are you alone?
Yeah, okay. Okay. Come here. Come on the hallway
Oh
What are we what are we doing we need to do a double
What's going on in here
Guys, I think mimosa is too tiny. All of us. She's imposter, but she's
I don't want to be with an imposter
I
That is gotta you do a double. Yes
I'm thinking
Thinking Mimi and Brian. Yeah
Hi
This is what this looks like. Hi
Wait
Chibi
I'm not the imposter
You are the imposter in the line engine output. What does that mean? Oh, it's up here
Bye
Hello, hello
I gotta go to the he's going down into I believe medby
He's out of medby incredibly quickly timing on chibi coming out of medby almost as if uninterested in any casmos
Hold on
We don't
Only rain. I found rain dead in the back of electrical. Nobody was nearby
But I have a feeling it might be rea and azura because they like to sit with each other
I saw mimosa and rea together. No, I saw. Yeah, isn't that suspicious?
I thought rea was here
Yeah, well, that doesn't mean they couldn't have vented from electrical to security rea and mersey are very
unlikely of had to do the time in order to do electrical unless mersey vented from below
But I actually wait, did I see you come on camera? I don't think that would make any sense. I think it's azura. I'm sorry, azura
Can you corroborate
Yeah, I need azura being fucking sus. I'm going for azura. Why are you sucking her toes, bro?
I didn't want you
It's because you know what you're talking about because you know what your tell is now, huh, strawnee?
So you're you're gonna keep quiet. I'm saying was strawnee because I I stuck with her in almost half
Thanks
You did that I'll stay on count. Oh, mersey's gonna fucking bowl with me
Don't press mersey either. She's fucking working on me. I'm talking most of said she was the imposter and so I was like bye
Okay
I'm so scared
Mosta is following Amy so whatever happens in that room. We're mostly in Amy or confer
No, ma'am. No, ma'am. It's I me. It's I me. It's I me. It's I me. It's I me
It's I me. She was sitting she pulled oxygen
She was just fucking
It was I me
When the oxygen is going down and we're all about to die. No, ma'am. No, motherfucking ma'am. No, ma'am. No, ma'am. No, ma'am
Bye
Get deleted. Bye
Why did you run so slowly to oxygen?
And you put in the code
I mean, you know
It doesn't take five seconds to type in a code
Okay, well, I guess we'll see I guess we'll see okay
Mosta if it's if it's not her
You've been screaming that you were the
Yeah, I could have murdered her
Yeah, well, maybe she wanted an alibi. Why are you defending the person that's trying to kill you?
Maybe you guys are both the the fucking imposters. I don't trust either one of you now
Well, she's acting like a sassy baka so she'll be
I'm sorry, I'm skipping
You're gonna get deep freeze then space. Goodbye. Well, it wouldn't be the first and it's not gonna be the last
I don't know. I'm gonna choose the one that I cast your vote. I cast your vote. Wait, who should I choose?
The most are I me
Come on, mercy
I meet I meet I meet. All right. Goodbye
Goodbye
I
Why don't you know just have open we gotta give we gotta give
Everybody's just screaming we gotta we gotta give each other
You gotta let the acute
Give her a boys
Yeah, Ray's been perfect the entire time. I bet she's gonna be imposter next round, but that's fine
All right, that's a little bit of karma. It's not black
It's okay. I'm just a very good lawyer. I'm not in a good way
I'm gonna make you sweaty more
Yo
I'm tired of sweating. Mommy memos is coming for you
Oh
Wait, I don't know where the fuck I'm going. There we go this way
The fight the
Ivy
Okay, okay, let her say her piece. Look, I like I found my freaking butt. I mean you were right next. I just saw you
No, I think it's rain
I think it's rain this time her voice is quivering
I think it's rain because when I was watching it, it was like rain satter. I can't even say anything
I swear it's rain. Her voice is so different. It's a pitch lower
I'm I'm skipping my vote. I'm I can't I'm upstanding. I'm upstanding
I literally walked away not knowing where I was going
Hey, listen, oh hi Mia. Listen, if the imposter wins, you guys are gonna lose. Okay. All right. That's all I have to say
All right, that was so quick. I couldn't get any information that round was insane
I
No, I was I was at wait shit. Where's where's the
OT didn't know where she was going just like me. I heard her walk away and I was laughing about it. Yeah. Oh too
Oh
Oh, oh, that's how I do it. I should honestly memorize this for next time when I'm imposter
Communications, I don't know where I'm going this one, right? Oh right here
Honestly when I'm doing chores when I'm not streaming guys
It's it's really like boring
It's like I'm doing my chores
What?
I'm doing my chores and then
Yeah, hold on. I'm still I'm still doing this thing
Oh, okay. Uh, I think mercy is fine
Where's the thing wait, where's the thing? I know it. Oh, well, we need we need oxygen
Let's go guys. I'm trying to run to it
I'm guarding you. I am I'm guarding you. I'm guarding you. Don't do it mercy
Okay, I did it. I'm proud of you. Good job. We're good
Pop, you did it. You did it
Oh, shoot. Where's my other thing? I don't know if I trust mercy. I don't know if I trust mercy. Follow me. I'm going to admin
Hi, hi
Oh my gosh, first try
Yeah
I fucking knew it. I fucking knew it. I told you your voice
I told you you're
Wait
Rain does she have a brain
Oh great
No, it's not rain. It's you. It's you rain. She's so sus
It's rain
I don't know where strongy was strongy. Uh, I saw her like a long time ago, but mercy was in the hallway
Why is she voting already? I'm so sus. I had walked all the way from weapons
Through cafeteria and then found her body there. Where rea rea. Where did you come from?
I went from so I I went in the circle. I went from admin to down and then through I think it's
Hold on. So you were the last one to see mercy
Yeah, I was I think actually
That is not helping. I'm voting rain because she's a sure yes. Oh my god, rain
Voting rain
Listen, I'm pretty sure I think that was so funny. Okay. I did
I was sitting there, but it's so innocent. She shouldn't have met the
No, poor rea. She has she has no thoughts
Yeah, I was literally too innocent
Well, I wasn't really
With your head, I thought it was I mean, I think it might be
I don't think it's I don't know anyone that I know it's I mean is one of them
Yes, I freaking know it. I we had every chance to kill me. We were alone so many times. No, no, I think she's in this track
I watched her do the oxygen
Maybe maybe maybe
Rain could not lie
I think she's grooming her. I think it's a zura and rain
It's horrible
I did I did see you walk past me, but you could have moved back around you might have been waiting for your moment
That's impossible because I literally ran past
No, it's not a zura. I don't think it's I think it's actually I me and rain. Listen, I know it
I actually discussed the whole right by me and rea. Oh, shit
It doesn't matter where you get out of here. Get out of here
You cheating conniving whore
That is so funny. I don't think I'll catch I'll catch on
Okay, but who's gonna be? I'm trying to help her. I mean, I mean, I mean, what's going on?
Uh, if they kill one of us, that means we lose so we confess you're a sin
Or we can hit the table oxygen depleted. It's a zura. It's a zura. It's a zura. I mean
Kill them kill them and let them know who you are
Just kill more people
I
My god
You were back stabbed I know
Why was rain so hard voting for her old
Dude, I was trying to help her so you guys wouldn't think it was her. No, I think the grooming is messy with my mind
Rea, please don't get groomed. Oh my goodness. I I burped. I'm so sorry
In my mouth
Rea you were with a zone
God rea is actually dumb
Where are you?
Miss girl
Masterclass rain strat
These don't let me be be teamed with rain because she'll backstab me
That was so funny
Anyways, I called it. I was like your voice is
Is it it was a good strat? It was a good strat
My god, mommy
I clothed you so fast
Oh, my god, I don't see it. It's your audio issues. Oh, okay. Oh, I'm sorry. I clothed you so fast
I know you don't need to be a little freaky pooh
Oh, you don't need to be a star or anything
Uh, this is how I cut catch senpai's in a wave
I have never felt so betrayed in my entire life
That was backstab me
Don't look at me anymore
Backstab is central
You're evil. I mean thanks for letting me win lunch. She needed a little help that round
We would you threw me onto the bus
Don't lie you like it you would never lie
You would lie behind me. I know you like being teased too little. You little I'm gonna smack your ass
Indulge rea. I mean, I'm sorry. I only loves being bullied and teased guys. She loves it
You see, you know
Gaslet is abuse
Hello, mommy
Mommy
I guess she's not gonna be able to listen to her
Oh, well, you don't need audio to play this game
Someone echoing someone echoing. Who is echoing? I would need it one's game is echoing. Oh, it's my job. What's my time? Oh, no, no
Reactor
Then admin later
I hate this one
That one was kind of hard senpai
I
Do do do do
Now it's kind of hard. Her audio is busted. She has to fix her audio
Hmm. I'm gonna download. Hi, mercy. Hi. I'm downloading too. What the hell same tasks?
Ah, fuck. My god, we're twinning
Ah, fuck. Okay, we gotta fix that
Hey, where the fuck did she go?
Did she vent
Oh
Wait, the entire room is dead help help
Ah, everyone's dead
No, the oxygen
It's freaking mercy
Listen
Listen, she was standing right there. I walk into the card room or whatever
Then I am used dead body and then mercy then reports. Why are we just standing? Yeah, that's kind of sus
I was doing I was doing the um, I was doing the downloads and I wouldn't let me go. Oh my god
I go fucking here. Hey, you got freaking nervous. She saw me. I was doing the download. So it was a self-report
No, the task is for doing a body
It's a self-report. I was doing the task. I didn't notice until I saw the body since started screaming
How do you not notice the body did a task before reporting a body on purpose? Yes or no?
I think it's mercy. It's the download thing. Well, you can vote for me if you want
But it's gonna say non faster than I'm gonna tell you told you so and then you know, I'm voting for you. I'm sorry mercy
Anyways, you're acting weird. If you vote for me if you want, that sounds very suspicious. Oh, you can vote for me
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah, go ahead. Go ahead. I'll prove you right. This is off topic
When that oxygen thing comes on, what do you did I look at the wrong part of the map for the oxygen?
Because I was trying to turn it back on
You can't tell where the right side of that. What's going on? Hey mercy, if it's not you, I'm sorry. I'm really sorry
Yeah, well, you should be
Why would she not report? Why would you do that for me? Why did I randomly get a vote? Because I'm doing oxygen
And you're saying what the fuck?
Oh, she wasn't a fuck.
Why did she just say that?
Funny ever again.
I can remember. I don't know why any of you ever trust Strony. I don't understand anything about her.
I don't understand anything about her.
I'm not trying to do the oxygen.
I was just trying to do the oxygen.
I was trying to do the oxygen.
I was trying to put the oxygen, but no, I'm still serious.
I'm still serious.
Okay, listen.
I was trying to do the oxygen.
Why would you do the oxygen? I sabotaged it.
I'm perfect.
Because I didn't know what to have an alibi to say that I'm top left when the fuck is used.
I don't care.
I'm in alcohol.
Right before I get kicked off, I will choose who the imposter is.
Okay, go for it.
Literally, I was looking at the map and it was flashing.
I'm like, where the F am I supposed to go?
Honestly, I walked in and I was like,
Me and Rhea were just swiping our cards, having a jolly good time.
I was literally like, one, three, two, one.
Literally, and they doubled us.
I was literally just standing there.
I was standing there because I literally was stuck at the Delos.
There was so much shock.
Bro, allegedly the horror.
They're like, oh, we must be safe.
I trust a word.
Never trust Ronnie.
Oh, Mercy, you're scaring me.
Mercy, you're scaring me.
Mercy!
I am.
No!
Momosa, Momosa, please!
Mercy is hunting me down.
Leave her alone!
Leave Brittany alone!
Laughing evilly and she's chasing me with a knife in her hand.
One knife!
Leave Brittany alone!
Oh wait, I'm here.
Why did y'all run there so late?
How the fuck did I do this one?
No, I was doing one task and I saw everyone go here.
I just pressed it twice.
It's not rare because she and I were the only ones.
Leave me alone.
I dropped Quarters in the cafeteria then.
Yeah, I was here first.
Nobody stabbing the back.
I'm very focused.
I protect.
Can I pet that dog?
No, they're doing the task.
I'm petting the dog.
Inazera.
We're gonna go fix this oxygen.
Mercy.
Mercy, hello!
Hello!
Hello! How are you?
Good! How are you?
I'm good.
I'm lost.
Where are you going?
Are you the imposter?
Whoa!
It means you never play.
Ivy's just not allowed to play.
She's not allowed to play.
She was chilling and shielding.
I saw me doing the reactor shit.
I don't know how this thing works.
I was a navigation.
Good.
I was doing wiring in front of Azure.
She was walking in the halls.
She was laughing easily chasing me down a hallway.
I ran into the open arms of Namosa.
She was really fun.
It's really funny.
Who were you with?
I was with Mercy.
Rain and Mercy.
Where was Raya?
Where was Raya at?
I was doing wiring.
I was also at the Xeroa point.
Xeroa, who are you accusing?
Speak your truth.
I didn't accuse anyone.
I have no clue what's going on.
Wait, that's so suspicious.
Right.
I'm going to say this.
Azure took a second to do any type of task.
She followed me from cafeteria
down to storage
and then parted ways out.
I don't believe you.
I was so excited about fixing my audio.
I was so happy.
That's also true and that's very on par for you.
I will say.
That is her thinking that loud.
I don't know about this.
Where was the dead body?
I just saw it.
Where's the location of the rain and Mercy?
Where's the shield?
I didn't see anyone nearby but the closest
was Rainn and Mercy.
They were by 02.
Where was I?
I'm not trying to figure out who the imposter is.
When I am the imposter
Oh no it's not me.
Wait.
She isn't talking to me this time.
He is not talking that much.
Just shove up your something.
No, I don't I think it's Marcy. I don't she's being sassy. I love
How about you all staying from existing?
My only my only inclination and my only inclination is my mom. Is that your cat's food dish? Yes
My only inclination is mimosa self-report is my only inclination and then my god, don't tell them
Abstain rain abstained looking at you will shifty eyes. Don't touch me
I don't know to believe either anyways who's most anyways, it's just fun
No, I don't I want to stay away from Marcy. Okay?
We're good
Wait, how'd I do this? Oh, I got it right
Oh
Azura it's Azura, dude, I think it's Azura. I saw her walking into electrical. Yeah
Electrical and found a body what the fuck?
Me and stronti are good. I was hanging out stronti looking at cameras
Being creepy I'm gonna vote for Marcy
Marcy who were you with or who did you see at any point in the map? I
Passed by mimosa. Oh
When you killed her no
It's rain, it's rain. It's really rain
But why where's the reasoning Azura
All right, all right, stronti stay with me stronti stronti stronti
I'm the last task. I don't know who the fuck is missing out on tasks, but we're literally
Fucking Marcy
You have to listen to us
Because her and Marcy almost doubled me and stronti
You guys were gonna double you guys were lining yourselves up to stab me in my butthole
Marcy it's Marcy it's Marcy stay away from the end I can't call it
She's a pocket pillow
Get that yandere off this ship right now. She's creeping me out
Chasing the and stronti when I actually have the chance to actually like pay attention
What is
Cuz I spent the entire game fucking with other shit and now I get to finally play
Yeah
Gamer
That was so fun. Let's go brothers
So an MLG group of among us unironically
Okay, now I want to act creepy towards Rhea
I just think it's fun
I'm following you like a creeper
Creeper creeper. I've never played minecraft creeper. Oh wait, this is where I'm supposed to be
At the clean the south
There we go. Oh, I need to do my tasks. I gotta go swipe my card. Yeah, let's follow each other
I'm trying to be creepy
Right, there's five so there's at least
Sometimes in this room how do I use it?
Swipe it. Oh my gosh. I got it in one go
Oh
It's my most I swear right I come here. I need my buddy. I need my buddy. Let's go to electrical together
Now you always say that when you're not
I
Need my buddy in my swipe card. I did my swipe card. Good job. How many times did it take like four
Are we looking at monitors rain stay away if you're imposter, I'll cover
You gotta go back to electric
Is it electrical
Which way is it? I swear. I swear it's mimosa
Oxygen
Oh
It's I mean I was chasing around them. I was chasing her and messing with her
I don't know
You guys are so dumb
I mean I mean
Don't
Yeah, I was gonna say are we ten or actually killer right now
We'll got voted out
Chibi, what is it happen?
Don't trust I be okay. Well, we'll just vote her off. She was so adamant
The same tears as before
Yeah, it's me too, okay, I don't I'm gonna abstain. I don't know I'm gonna do what I must
I'm doing what I must I'm doing what I must I don't trust you
I just want to kill everyone else
Okay, okay, I fucking knew it. Okay, I'm gonna be over here
Okay, how'd I fix everything flashy lights, how'd I fix it? Oh
Everything's fixed
It's everything fixed
No, why is it so quiet
I
Got one more
Everything's too quiet too quiet
I finished my tasks
Where is everyone I'm terrified
Wait, where is everyone?
Oh
Chibi's dad finder I found her in what's that area Med Bay
Med Bay I said I found her in Med Bay. I finished my task and then I was like where the fuck is everyone?
It's Tony. It's Tony. Hey, why is it fucking me?
Because I was in wiring admin with Azure. Yeah. Yeah, it's Tony. Why because
Accusations
No
It's Marysie self report and I will tell you
Oh
Wait, no, it's Marysie. No, it's
It's Azra
I swear
Rae, Rae
Listen listen to Azra's voice her voice is slightly higher pitch the new usual
What do you mean? No, no, no, no, she's trying to gaslight you. I'm not gaslighting you
I we've hung out the entire time. No, we've hung out the entire time. It's Marysie
I can't believe it
It's always the cute one
Vented and killed me in Med Bay
I was like, oh shit
Marysie
But you instantly went for me when I
It's because you said it was mercy
When I get imposter you're dying first. I'm not even kidding
You're so funny
Marysie, I thought I thought she said it was Marysie and I knew Marysie was innocent
I thought Marysie was innocent because what Marysie said
Everyone's always suspects me
Everyone just suspects me it's unfair
It's unfair that everyone thinks it's me
I
See are you gonna get me? What are you doing? I'm just doing my tasks Marysie
Did you I witnessed that
I should have known
Give me a second
I'm telling them I got kicked out
Anyways, it was really fun guys it was super fun to just you know kill everyone
I just had to chase I'm so glad that I was able to chase she be down and went
And getting right yeah
Honestly, I just wanted to creep people out because it's fun
I I've never gotten imposter this many times, you know
I've never gotten imposter this many times so I was like
Honestly creeping people out it's just fun just fun
Okay, okay, give me a second. I'm gonna get back in ten pies
I'm gonna have to enter the code
It's not letting me in
I
Did you try unplugging it and plugging it back in again, I mean I might have to
Oh, there we go we got in
We got it
In the lobby
I fucking love when there's four people
When there's two of us together, I love going three to one
Satisfying so satisfying in like execute the plan with a woman
Anyways, my next goal is to follow someone just for fun
Just to wait the movie. Why do you sound so far away?
Oh
I forgot I forgot she has like an actual place to live and doesn't work in our basement like me
Right next to her guess that's cool. I want food right next to me. Honestly, Ray. I was too good
I like believed her. I believed her innocent
She's such a good liar believe you're capable of anything
You didn't change your tone of voice at all when lying yo, why is my peeing dancing like that?
Never trust Rhea, I can't tell she's one of a few people I can't tell
My mouth is dry, I'm sorry
I just noticed your voice
Notice your voice is so beautiful. I
Believed her to the end as well dead ass. I believe ran to the end
I can never tell
Until by the anger in my voice when I get accused wrongly
Every time you you you don't let someone finish
It feels like you're being defensive and not letting the person speak. So you know cuz you
Yeah, you gotta let me you gotta give me the bill. Yeah, let me explain the reason because you're
You gotta let me explain why and then you have a okay why I'm wrong
Because the only reason I got that last game is because you voted so quickly
I wanted to I thought strong you with suspicious anyways, it just feels good
Yeah, the Scottish right the Scottish one suspicious. I see how it is
That's it. You're getting set as the alveolar members officially
suspended for 48 days no pain
40 days for any way
You're really good. Yeah, so I'll say one thing the girls have never seen me
Any other type of motion other than like happy and proud of their work
So playing among us when I'm screaming down the make being like it's fucking
It's probably quite a surprise
I want to see a Zara and rea or scrawny and rea team up. That's what I want to say
scrawny and rea will probably
The statistics of a Zara being imposter very high. No, just keep that in mind by the way, it's my improbability statistics
They're all fun to mess with I'm eating bold
I
Because he says the
I'm gonna be wait, wait, wait, wait, who said that the most out you're on my hit list
Wait, no, I'm supposed to be over here
I
Trust nobody everybody says I don't trust nobody
What what we just did
Okay
I
Can't find where I'm going. I'm almost done my task
Wait
There was the other body. Oh my god
Oh my god
Where was everyone I was about to report
Wait, wait, where's my where's my thing?
I saw scrawny I passed by those two. I was an electrical there was a body there
Um well first of all
Secondly, I was shooting asteroids and I walked out and there's a body at oxygen and it was mimosa
By is anyone being a navigation or two or weapons yes or no, no, I was in cafeteria
I was about to do electrical. It was cafeteria. I know it's scrawny. I just know it's scrawny. I just know it's scrawny
Are you fucking wait hold on a minute?
Hold on a minute. I say who's been near weapons oh to navigation because you have reported the body and where oh to
And you automatically go it's scrawny. Sorry. I know you love playing these mind games be like it's scrawny
It's scrawny. Forget it. Fuck
It's fucking she be
Because I'm nice and calm and she's freaking out
Cuz you're picking on me when you were self-reported the body when you're the only person who's been witnessing with an auto navigation
Yeah, it could be both of them body must have been there
report because no one else has been there
I mean, who are you with again?
And
Yeah, I was with Amy because we were hanging out. Oh, yes, he was right his body
Because she was alive and then when she walked off and then that's and then I was singing a song
The round goes fast is scrawny cuz Johnny kills fast
Thank you
I
Okay, goodbye
The moment she starts getting defensive and loud
She
You were the only person in that area because I killed her long ago in that area. No, that's what I mean
I'm like, I had to have happened long ago. I can't believe mommy would do this
The next time I'll kill her first you betrayed me
Excuse me, which you guys could see all the gesturing that I'm doing right now
Look at our cute little rival queen of gas
Press the button. Thank you
It's like
I want to feel like
I crave blood and death
I'm defending myself against that she be
I'm gonna get fucking
Don't be angry
You're so hot
Hi
All right, um Mamosa
Why are you guys following me?
Why
Cuz I like you. Oh, okay, I like you too then
But I swear if you fucking tell me like then the one second of trust I have I'm gonna be so mad
It'll go down the toilet. Yeah, it will go down the toilet like now
Left left side of the map near security
Where
Hey, I want everyone to tell me their location right now
I
Whatever it's called
Open up the map
What it's our rain
It's not me guys fucking a Zura
No, no, I'm not saying it's you I'm saying it's rain
No, let me vouch for people. It's not a zero or she be okay. Look, let's see. I'm vouching for people right now
It's definitely cuz she be was following me and then I was following you're kind of quiet
Then Amy. I mean was sniffing my ass
Look, I don't want to accuse my gym, but I'm me like you're a little bit quieter than usually are Johnny
Why are you so quiet?
I'm so quiet cuz I've asked the same question five times and everyone has ignored my question
Everyone identify your location on the map right now open up map top right and I'm in storage
We're on our way to cafeteria is there an eye I was
Who's in storage? I was in storage with I'my. That is me and she be
I mean, so then mercy and I'my then
I will only say that I was not with rain the entire time
I think it's mercy why
I think it's I think it's mercy I mean trust me
Well, I'm voting rain. I'm going whatever
I would like to also mention mercy did not defend herself once during that execution
Mercy what the hell
Man, I don't know man. I don't know man. I don't know man. I believe I don't know man
My mic is not picking up as normal
I get to fuck you get to fuck
I
Actually, don't trust you mercy's following
Just doing like a big
I can bomb it
Shibby
But I knew it was mercy to I had a feeling
Ronnie said that mercy was quiet. That's when I knew
Oh, yeah, I knew it was I didn't get a chance to say if I get changed
He was I saw mercy mercy was the last person
Round as well. I could tell it was she be I just abide by time
I knew it was mercy because mercy was the last one with Rhea and I was trying to tell you guys that you know
I know you're sitting the ass of a killer
I
Honestly
Sorry my mind play was to make myself look more suspicious than everyone else
Why don't trust the what are you a princess?
I
Swear to fuck I me if you touch my butt while this happens. I'm gonna cry
Okay, I guess I'm crying. Okay. I'm so anxious right now. I cannot please don't destroy me
Ray any time you I don't trust Rhea, but still nothing, but
Where's this one? Oh fuck. Oh shit. Oh
Fuck oh
Fuck oh shit. Oh fuck. Oh shit. Ah
Okay, I'm gonna you more support you okay, okay
Wait, where's everyone and why isn't it working?
Are you are you literate
Skill is you sabotage you supposed to fix it
Not the skill I was good. We didn't even have to do anything. I just took out mimosa on the way
I
Killed the most of before she can start we don't have our eight. We don't have our eight
There we go
Yes, we got our eight. Oh my god. All right, that scared me. Sorry
Here I
Don't want to do two of them two of them at the same time
Monster
Dude, I've been a boxer like what five times already is crazy
Rain you're not
This round honestly
Honestly
I've never used this feature
Or
See come with us
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, it's fine. There's five of us. There's five of us. It's fine
Okay
Wait, hold on rail, why did you walk right past that?
I
Was coming no, no, no, Ray is fine. Ray is fine. I watched your skin. I watched mercy
Okay, I did it. I was on cans. I saw a zero coming out of them. I did it. I killed scrawny
Yeah
I
Was in medbay at medbay I watched her do a skin
What scrawny okay, and then mercy kills. It's not a zero
I'm just vouching for because I saw Sarah. I saw a zero walk in that direction towards
Whatever, it's called the navigation. I think she's fine. Yeah, I think
Think it's mercy
I'm gonna be really upset because I
Why did you report her body?
I did it. It's mimosa and mercy. I trust trust think I don't know. I think it's you and no
I ran into the body. I was I was the one who reported it. I wasn't there. Yeah. No mimosas. Fine. Mimosas. I
Did it I killed scrawny
Okay, I ran to mimosa in fear
You vote for yourself
How was it idle meeting girly pop? That's why she's like kill me
Oh
We don't have to worry about a double
You
Sorry, sorry, I'm back
I didn't even get nervous for that issue. I was just running around the map, which is crazy
I'm just teasing. I'm sorry
Sorry, I'm back. I'm back
Am I still streaming Senpai Senpai
Senpai Senpai am I am I
Am I
Am I oh shit
Oh my gosh, I'm lagging so badly
My internet be the poo poo pee pee poo poo internet pee pee poo poo
Internet pee pee poo poo
I
I sp I paid premium
Premium
It's chat good it's chat good I feel like people are like saying that I'm lagging
Yeah, give us a sign
I'm here. I'm here
Okay, it seems we're fine now
Sorry about that dang
I don't know what happened
Oh
I'm gonna try again. They said they're they're gonna throw it. Yeah, I'm in
I'm in so sorry. You want a time it is. Yeah, I'm gonna mute right now hold on
You can still hear it. Okay, it's not me then
Someone's proximity all right someone in the middle come to the edge if it's not if you don't I'm gonna mute. Hang on
Let me see
It's gone. It's gone. I don't know who you fixed it. I didn't you
Getting a guy who's called geiger counter for radiation. I know seriously
It's not me is it
I'm ready
They're gone
It might be me
If it's audio problems, it might be me
It's I mean
I'm going over here. Hi, Azora
Uh
Perk six height three six 92 pounds purple
B to D
Ah
I said hi
Azora, how could you do such a thing?
Oh
My god
Oh, shit anyways, she be azora you too, mommy
Oh
Okay, it's oh
Mercy's dead on the mid base scanning pad
Oh
Because it was you I wasn't near medbay. I was all around the perimeter
It saw me doing the leaves
And I was on cam now it's drawny. That's us. That's us. That's us. Self report
And then I went to great
Hold on hold on who just
One more time for me
Who said who who said straw knee three times in a row do it again. I dare you
Is that mimosa right it's mimosa then self report it's it's mimosa
No, no, no, no, it's
That's right. Let me go. It's mimosa because
I'm sitting there going yeah, it's a self report
Rain and now we're together. Yeah, it's the first thing you claimed even though I already
Ran rare with together
I don't know if it's straw knee or mimosa. I don't know if it's straw knee or mimosa
I'm not even sweating. Mimosa?
I don't know if you want later tonight. We can talk about it later because
I think it's the straw knee
Oh, no, I will let you finish
All right, I will let you finish
I'm 100. Okay when you're finished. I'll say my piece. Okay. I'm done, baby. I'm done. You speak. Do you guys hear that too?
One of my is it me? I'm gonna take that as my it's now my turn the person who reported the dead body
Yeah, mimosa. So I thought nice try fucking trying to get me. Yeah. Bye. You're gonna be attracted next. Bye. Put in your mouth
Your girlfriend smells like trash
They're so naughty
What the fuck? It's not me. It's not me. She fucking void me. So I thought she was so
She's literally not me
It's so great
Anyways, who am I haunting?
It's the Jots
Azra, you killed me
Azra
Enough on me because we can't even believe for a second that I might be a wee bit nice in this video
Cookies
Chicken nuggets
Oh
I'm so nervous
What's happening? What's happening?
Yeah, like, couldn't shut the app your arse. Honestly
That was good
That was good. I liked that
I'm gonna come back
The most so
I wouldn't have written a poll that gave
I'm sorry I couldn't
I couldn't focus. I just kept hearing
I just kept hearing where she's ghost
I don't hear it too
I'm sorry
I'm saying because I knew if I voted
The most so
You came out swinging against me with absolutely nothing to your name
Of course I thought you were sauce
You did the same thing to me when we both were innocent
Oh my gosh
She just accuses
It doesn't listen people out
It doesn't listen to people
I tried to let everyone have a fucking go at me
Wait, hold on
I was about to just
Wait, wait, listen
I was about to like say food
I was like y'all's a chicken nuggets
A reefling has said
It's not about Stormy being nice or not
It's about me being dangerous
Which has been proven in previous rounds
So none of you believe me
When I'm freaking a crewmate
Yeah, it's true
Every time we start
You always say that it's probably always going to be someone
Or you say that we're always
Because I'm trying to figure out who it is
I'm like trying to figure out
I'm trying to be like
Okay, thank you for voting
Unfortunately, we're misfired
We missed
Alright, last game, make it count
Hope Strawny's an imposter
Oh, I'm an imposter, right?
I'm going for Mercy first
Why are you going for me first?
Cause I'm an imposter
Nooooo
Sorry, Mercy, I'll guard you
It'll be so funny if like
It is Strawny and she comes to kill Mercy
I can't fucking do this
I'm really focused on this card read
Can you guys go do that?
Okay, I got it
How do I get there?
Oh shit, I went the wrong way
Oh, is it done?
It's me, I killed Mercy
Well, no, it's not, I was actually just with Strawny
Oh, so now you don't want to accuse me
Cause I saw you talking
You were talking to the wall
Talking to your chat and it was quite cute
So I was just staring at you
So it wasn't you
Uh, it's okay
I wanted to do my tasks
Is that the two of you?
I mean
I got killed by Raine
They're not gonna believe you
No, they're not gonna believe you
It happened so fast, I wasn't paying attention
They're not gonna believe you
Hold on
Dude
Yeah, I'm really worried
Dude, what the fuck
Tear work is crazy
No
Hold on
Are they gonna get it?
Are they gonna get Raine on the first try?
Wait, what's the dealio?
So Mamosa finds the body where?
Outside of reactor
It was two of them
Sade of reactor
Raine, you're vouching for Ria and Mamosa
Raine, sorry
I was vouching for Ria and Mamosa
Wait, but I'm not vouching for Raine
I'm not vouching for Raine cause I didn't see
I don't know
I was just swiping a card
Yeah, to be honest
I told you guys to go worry about it
You can tell
Yeah, it's me, but me
Okay, it's Raine
Cause she's being too quiet
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Raine's being too quiet
Thanks for voting me
Well, it's very kind of you to think about me
The audience is obviously
Strony
Yeah, yeah, yeah
Throw Strony into easy peasy
Lemon squeeze
If I die, Strony killed me
Ria!
She's a little bastard
I'm so proud of her
She's using my strat
I can't believe you anyways
Ria!
You monster!
You innocent little baby
Goo Goo Gaga
Ria!
Yeah, it's not me and Strony
We're busy
What's going on guys?
I'm on my fifth try
Come on
She's such a good liar
She's like
It's between Amy and Mamosa
Yeah, cause me and me and
Strony were hanging out on medbay
I believe Ria's claim on the fifth card
Swipe no offense
I believe you are
Mamosa, say your piece
Her voice does not change tones
Goodbye
I'm so cute
She's so cute
They don't even suspect her
I don't know who to vote for
I know, she has to
It's Mamosa then
Oh my god
Yeah, we were touching her on the medbay
Is she gonna get away with it?
She might get away with this by herself
She's all
What?
Mamosa, why?
Why?
Mamosa, she couldn't kill me at any time
I know, I know
Goo Goo Gaga
Baby Ria
Confess your sins
Yes
It's
Oh
We're haunting you
Murderer
Ria
Confess your sins
Sin
Goo Goo Gaga
Baby
We love you Ria, you can do this love
Don't listen to me
No, don't listen to your partner
Someone left their baby
Yeah, it was Azra
My baby
Notice the gyoza
They killed a mother with a baby
Did somebody leave?
She pulled a clutch that's actually crazy
I'm so proud of her, oh my god
Wait, what happened?
You guys don't clear the sabotage
No one ever clears the sabotage
What?
Oh, it's the lights
Yeah, it's the lights
So if you don't fix it
No, not the lights
The lights doesn't
Yeah, I said that we won
Okay
Oh, crewmates won?
I see crewmates
Oh, did you finish all your tasks?
Nice
Are we satisfied?
I'm happy
I want one more, I'm not satisfied
One more
Wait, where's Ria?
Where's Ria to cross?
Oh, Ria called Kate, hold on
Ria called Kate, give her a second
There she is
I'm so proud of you
Welcome back
To go back
My vaude
I'm so proud of her
I am
We didn't even clear the task
I was so close to
I was so close
She's such an evil being
I don't know who the other imposter was
Who's the other imposter?
Rain and Ria
Oh, it was Rain
I had a feeling it was
Med Bay
Why guard me in Med Bay?
I swear I will haunt you
and say words
What's the emergency?
I covered emergency
Oh, okay, okay
Okay, let's go
I covered emergency, it's not you
No, the lights, hold on
Oh, it's the wrong way
I went the wrong way
Wait, where is everyone?
I saw Azra
No, no, it was
It was Azra
Someone got disconnected
and that's why the game ended
That's why
I was with Ria and Ria
and Electric
We have an alibi
It was Azra
I saw Azra
I saw her killer
We were together
You both were together in Med Bay
and I walked into Med Bay
and then we walked
You both were together
We both saw you
You're so quiet
They're busy pointing fingers
Wait, who said strong?
Who said strong is quiet?
Listen to me
Wait, listen to me
We were talking
Me and Ame were looking
outside of Med Bay
Mercy and
Mercy and Rain
were in Med Bay together
Ame went off
and I went down
and Rain was dead
You want me to tell my story?
I walked into Med Bay
I did the little thing
I was purple 3
because I didn't trust Rain
and then I walked outside
I lost Rain for a second
and I saw Azra kill Rain
I saw the body
You've been so good at gaslighting
I'm not good at gaslighting
I'll just fucking say it
I've had so many elves
I've had so many elves this entire time
I never think it's you
It's Azra but I'm gonna skip
You're gonna
She's gonna aim for me next
Trust me
I was with Ame
Aimee were you there?
Were you there?
Aimee
Oh my god
I saw Azra
I didn't see anyone else
Oh my gosh is it Aimee and Azra?
I think it's Mercy
Her voice cracked telling her story
It's a bit shaky
It was
She went for tours
Watch
Not
Watch this
It's Azra
Oh no
It's not me
It's really not me
Because there is
In Medbay
Keeping an eye
Keeping an eye on Azra
You just stay with me
It's not me
Chicken nuggets
Chicken wings
French fries
Potato chips
Cookies
Oreos
Goldfish
I told ya
Step through the heart
I should have voted for it
Even if I voted for Azra it would have been a tie
I had a feeling
I forgot a positive happy cast
That was good
I'm now satisfied
Everybody she's satisfied
I'm satisfied now
She's so happy now
She's so happy
She won
That was fantastic
That was so good
I love the friendship
We gotta play Garchic Phone with you guys
You guys
You guys trust me at all
We do
Great is evil
This is
But Strani is dangerous in game
Strani is a dangerous
She knows too much
And she also like
Very sleepy
I'm proud of Rea
Rea's voice never falters when she's in the roster
Rea is also cutely evil
Rea is so good at this game
She gets away with so much
And no one just trusts me
Nobody trusts me
I'm so proud of you
I got disconnected
I was about to win
Her eye will laugh
I'll give it to you
So indulge Grelly
Thank you for doing this collab with us
You're doing remedy girls
Thanks for having us
Indulge in your remedy
Indulging in your remedy
So hard right now
Draw it right now
Draw it
Like the logos together
Alright
I was like
What are we commissioning exactly
I see
Oh dear
Thank you so so much
I'm going to leave the lobby
And I'm going to say a little good bye to my chat
Thank you so so much
For having us
It's been fantastic
Close off the game the new
And jump into that voice chat
Thank you very much
Bye
Hold on I got to get out of chat
Get out of the call
Gotta just
Chatting
Ah dang it
I knew I forgot something
I forgot the chat box
That was really fun wasn't it
Hold on
There you go
Did you have fun
Senpai
It was hilarious right
I think I was imposter
Way too many times
And I honestly feel like I should be imposter less
Usually I don't ever get imposter
I don't get imposter
Usually I don't get imposter
But do you guys like the human plus girls
If you like the human plus girls
They are so cute
They are so kind
Don't forget to like
Subscribe to them
They are so
They are the sweetest girls ever
They've been so kind to us
And yeah I really love
Hang out with more purple girls
And do more collabs like this
I think it would be great
Are we allowed to do things like that
Well
Yes but also
If you're like
I actually like this girl better than you
Then I might get a little
I think I might get a little jealous
By a little I mean a lot jealous
And I might get
I might steal your hammer and just
Understood?
I might get a little jealous
I might get a little a lot jealous
But honestly I feel like
You will enjoy them
You enjoy them quite a bit
Especially if
You know having more choices around
Is totally fun
I will
I
It's fine, it's fine
But like
Let's talk about like kayfabe
Kayfabe and stuff outside of kayfabe
It's
It's perfectly fine
It's perfectly fine but I will get a bit jealous
If I see you in their chat a little bit
More and then I see you a little less
From me
I might have to make a
Vacancy
You might find yourself
With a bone saw
Between your arms
Cutting
Your bones apart
But honestly
Honestly great fun
Great fun
I would
I want to see
I definitely want
To have more collabs
Since it's
It's really fun especially
Corporal unity you know
We love corporal unity here
Because
All of us are small corpals
Trying to get by
I had lots of fun
I will never blame the girls
But I will blame my senpai
Real fast
Cool
I have eyes everywhere except for the room
With three dead bodies
You saw I was stuck
I was stuck
I was like no it's downloading
Shit
That was
That was definitely fun
That was definitely
A pawn moment
Pawn moment from me
I was like wait
Wait a second that's like three bodies
What the fuck
So used
So used to
To dead bodies that I'm just like
Oh shit I didn't fuck
I didn't notice
Was so used to it
It was on the eye patch side
So I couldn't help it
Yeah that's real
You ever just like
Suddenly go
Oh
I see
But yeah
Let's go over our schedule again
Let's see what my schedule is like
Tomorrow
I'm playing I'm continuing
Death mark
And then after that I have nothing
For the rest of the week except
For
My SMT knock turn
Memba stream
So
Remember
That it's on
Friday
And we'll make it
Memberable
Yeah
So
So remember
It is a member's only stream
Remember
If you want to
Membralize it
So yeah that's on Friday
Regular time at 11pm
E.D.T.
So if you don't have work
Bye if you do have work
You can watch me at work
So yeah
Please join me for that
Next week
I'm still
Working around next week's schedule
And hopefully we'll have
A good old time
Talk about stuff
Hopefully it's enjoyable
It's enjoyable for a member's stream
It's gonna be my first member's stream
Thank you everyone for joining me today
And I hope you enjoyed our collab
With Yume Plus
Please subscribe to the Yume Plus girls
Give them a few watches
Give them a few likes, maybe a comment for two
And I'll see you again
Next time
Tomorrow, to be exact
Okay, remember
Stream for Mercy
Yeah
Bye-bye
Bye
Thank you